the world we live in seems to us
rather clear cut it's hard for us to
imagine
flying mountains enormous space
anomalies
or objects thousands of times the size
of the sun however
a lot of what would normally seem to be
a figment of one's imagination
actually exists in the universe however
it is billions of kilometers away from
us
a perfect example of these eerie
celestial objects
are black holes their sheer existence
was considered impossible until only
recently
when on the 10th of april 2019
the national science foundation in the
usa showed the world an image
revealing a black hole in the middle of
the messier 87 galaxy
this object has a mass approximately 6.6
billion times
that of the sun with a diameter of about
a hundred billion kilometers
just to compare the diameter of the
earth is only 12
740 kilometers this hole
falls into the category of supermassive
black holes
a similar object can also be found in
the center of the milky way
it is called sagittarius a and boasts
from 2 to
5 million times the sun's mass according
to different estimates
the diameter of sagittarius a is 45
astronomical units
in other words 45 times the distance
from the earth to the sun
but is it possible to admit of the
existence of even larger black holes in
space
and which of them is the largest let's
figure it out
a black hole is a term referring to an
area
in space with an incredibly powerful
gravitation
in the center as a rule these objects
are rather small at first
and are able to expand as they actively
build up their masses
black holes are categorized according to
their masses
the heavier ones are called supermassive
black holes
those of them whose masses reach from a
hundred thousand
to ten billion times the mass of the sun
fall into this category at the moment
scientists
haven't formed a unanimous opinion as to
how these objects come about in space
according to the most popular theory
that of gradual expansion
when a black hole appears it has a mass
typical of a star
and later on it grows by sucking in the
surrounding matter
the amount of information accumulated by
science about these objects is rather
scarce
but even based on the current data a
supposition can easily be made about
there being at least
several such holes in the center of any
large galaxy
in the time the universe has existed a
few million
or even billion of black holes are
likely to have been formed in it by now
at least today only a small fraction of
them
is known to us the champion in terms of
its mass
is the black hole in the center of a
quasar
known as 10618 this
object was stumbled upon in 1957
when white dwarfs were being explored
and initially caused a lot of puzzlement
on the part of the scientists
the notion of quasars was to appear only
six years later
that is why the nature of the object was
rather vague
on photographic plates taken with a 0.7
meter schmidt telescope
it was listed as number 618 and
described as decidedly violet
it was only in 1970 that radio mission
from
10618 was discovered at the institute
for radio astronomy of bologna
this emission was indicative of the fact
that it was a quasar
and moreover the most luminous quasar
known to science at the time
it is assumed that there's an accretion
disk of hot gas in tons
618 surrounding a gargantuan black hole
in the center of the galaxy
the gas must move around the disk at a
tremendous speed
reaching 7 000 kilometers per second
this object is located in the
constellation of hunting dogs
arcanes venatici and is 10.37 billion
light years away from us
the galaxy containing tons-618 cannot be
seen from the earth due to the
luminosity of the quasar itself
which is 140 trillion times as intense
as that of the sun
the contemporary review on quasars
defines them as active nuclei of
galaxies
at the first stage of their formation
the nuclei's supermassive black hole
sucks in the surrounding matter thus
forming an accretion disk
this disc is the source of luminosity of
enormous
power that is sometimes more intense
than the aggregate luminosity of all
stars and galaxies like ours
the brightest quasar which was
discovered in january 2019
has the luminosity of about 600 trillion
suns
and is 12.8 billion light years away
from the earth
what could be the mass of an object
finding itself in the center of a light
cannon like this
according to today's estimates the mass
of the black hole in the center of the
10618 quasar
reaches 66 billion times the sun's mass
which makes it the heaviest black hole
in our galaxy
known to science black holes of this
mass
are categorized in a different group and
are referred to as ultra massive black
holes
in fact the ton 618 quasar
isn't the only object in this category
within the constellation of cancer for
example which is 3.5 billion light years
away from us
the oj287 quasar is to be
found it has a black hole in the center
and is 18 billion sun's masses
in the center of the phoenix cluster
there's a rapidly expanding black hole
which at this moment is 20 billion times
the sun's mass
building up 60 suns masses a year
one of the best known black hail giants
is located in the galaxy
ngc 127c within the perseus
constellation
the object reaches 21 billion suns
masses
and its event horizon diameter equals
130 billion kilometers
which is 15 times the distance from
neptune to the sun
however at the moment this giant
practically isn't being active
speaking about size the undisputed
holder of the first
place on the list is admittedly another
well-known space object
namely the black hole in the center of
helmberg 15a
a supermassive elliptical galaxy located
in the constellation cetus
or the whale 700 million light years
away from the earth
this black hole isn't a champion in
terms of its mass
which is 40 billion times the sun's mass
its dimensions however can't but amaze
according to today's estimates
the event horizon of this black hole
could be as big as to accommodate the
entire
solar system its diameter is
approximately
790 astronomical units
the helmberg 15a galaxy must have been
formed as a result of the collision of
two smaller galaxies
at some point in the distant past
a similar process is likely to be
expected in our system as well
when the milky way collides with the
andromeda galaxy in 4 billion years time
for now astronomers plan to continue
studying the phenomenon of the black
hole and holmberg 15a
by carrying out complex and detailed
modelling
scientists are going to collate the
results of theoretical calculations with
practical observations in the future
in order to try to establish how exactly
it was possible for a tremendous black
hole
to come into being inside the two
galaxies on their collision
in comparison to the objects mentioned
above our own planet may seem of no
significance at all on the overall space
map
but it should be noted that the age of
practically all the supermassive objects
in the universe
is several times that of our earth
for millions of years these black holes
have been gaining in their masses and
expanding as the time went by
today we can observe their activeness as
the result of the development of the
entire universe
it is quite feasible that most of the
ultra massive black holes were formed as
a result of smaller holes merging
a similar process takes place when they
collide which is accompanied by the
emission of gravitational waves
these occurrences must be the biggest
contributors to the generating
gravitational waves in the universe
and are exceptionally attractive to
scholars of gravitational wave astronomy
by now several similar signals which
came about as a result of two small
black holes merging have been registered
by the american observatory ligo
perhaps we will find out the names of
other champions in the list of space
giants in the near future
and now all we have left to do is just
await new
amazing discoveries
we respect our audience that is you dear
viewers
that's why we try to bring out the
scrutiny the most fascinating and
bizarre
things that can be found in space so
diverse
and amazing that's why grab this mouse
of yours and hit the like button
under the video it's your likes and
comments that encourage us to explore
new boundaries
we will make it beyond these only thanks
to your support
and your subscription to the channel see
you around dear friends
[Music]
you